maintenant et vous joey starr quand je
vais maintenant que va se dire 'je oui
pour moi tu es la plus grande star de
ces trente dernières années
ah ouais te le dis mais c'est vrai voilà
et je n'ai aucune dent contre toi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
hashtag couronne de roi
ben quoi c'est le roi oui donc je le
fais tout de suite voilà je vais le
faire tout de suite
donc je le fais tout ça les ai dit
qu'est ce que j'avais dit joe et sa
gérante dernières années mais c'est bon
c'est bon - joey c'est joey starr qui
s'appelle we celui-ci d'accord je les
tue est la plus grande star voilà de
ckoi 20 au même dit ça peut se passer
ouais bon de cdd de ces dix dernières
années enfin bon enfin vingt dernières
années
voilà un lin dernières années voilà
meilleur à ses chiens
bah oui c'est un truc plus familiers
comme intel saignait l'appel didot ou du
tout le monde dit doux excuse moi tes
idées tu peux te les garder
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
puis vingt dernières années et je n'ai
aucune banque n'a pas failli et où tu
crois quoi toi n'avait pas voilà je n'ai
aucune dent contre toi ta meuf haute une
dent contre toi voilà très bien un tuner
couronnées et et #ows pas qu'on lâche ta
couronne hashtag voilà acheter quoi pas
de pizza
à chaque couronne a ajouté que médias
c'est très drôle bravo bon bah très bien
merci moi je les fais vous de leur mot à
sa part non non non on n'a pas dit que
tu es encore pas très bien où il va le
faire la presse ça parle de jeu par
l'auteur de rythme voilà que ça ralentit
un peu comme ben oui c'est vrai merci
mes chéris merci tout le monde a fait